[Music]
hey you guys it's [ __ ] monday yeah i
know
yeah so we're gonna do uh new cherry
flavor brand new cherry paper i saw some
of the episodes they're pretty good but
all in all like i kind of started to
lose interest and i i had other [ __ ] i
had to do
so i kind of stopped watching them but
jenny continued to watch them every time
i popped back in it looked good
if i'd had the time i probably would
have been was seeing them all but i'm
gonna let her handle it
um
i will tell you guys this though
i was sitting in front of tv
in the room
was it after lunch or before lunch do
you remember it was early this morning
it was early this morning i think it was
and pookie wrestles with me every
morning she runs up she starts wrestling
and i'm grabbing her like that and she's
ah she's on her back wrestling and then
doing she's going to run and then she's
a terrible face yeah and then she'll run
then she'll come running at me [ __ ]
straight ahead and boo grabbed me and
[ __ ]
so i'm watching tv and wrestling with
her
and i was had her down there like that
on her [ __ ] back and she's going ah
like that and she jumps up and runs
and i looked up for the television and
she [ __ ] went about three feet and
came back down and
boom rolled her over on her back and
she's ah fighting and i put my hand down
like that and i was looking at what she
was fighting
the motorcycle key
yep
she had the [ __ ] key
all my [ __ ] hair stood up like that i
don't have much hair all the hair fog
was like whoa
and she had the key and she was
chewing on it and she didn't have it two
seconds ago and there there's nowhere
that she could have got that dab key
we can't figure out uh where it came
from
culture guys gave her the key i kind of
feel like well because remember i think
it was even on the live stream i asked
the poltergeist very nicely to bring the
key back and that was like a day or two
ago and i just and it was obviously that
she had the key and i was just wrestling
with her like two seconds before and
when she came back she had the key
and she was on her back [ __ ] biting
it and fighting it with her back paws
like i threw it to her
and we can't figure out where it came
from yeah she didn't question where it
came because you like tore up all that
you put picked up the table the tv is on
it's like took everything off the table
under the bed under the thing at the end
of the bed it's just like it wasn't
there she didn't have it before and it
was nowhere i checked everywhere within
10 meters so 20 meters of that
front of that television where i sit
there on that little chest thing it was
nowhere around
told you guys threw it to her
i guess she didn't question it she just
grabbed she was like whatever yes
she didn't see where it came from she
just grabbed it the ghost threw it to me
[Laughter]
some weird [ __ ] maybe she sees ghosts
all the time i don't think she saw it i
think she thought i threw it to her
yeah maybe it probably feels i didn't
see it isn't that funny
you never see it arrive you never see it
where it comes from you just see it
arrive or it's just there
and it happened fast it's pretty spooky
real [ __ ] spooky my hair [ __ ]
stupid
he came and i was in my i was in my
office he comes in my office and he's
like no no no no no no and i'm like
what's the matter with you and he put
the key down yeah on my laptop yeah and
i was like where the [ __ ] did that come
from pookie had it hooky had it but
it appeared in her little paws yeah like
she was playing with it but she wasn't
playing with it a minute not even a
minute two to three seconds
that's great she went and she ran just
like
three feet and then turned around
threw herself on her back and was like
and doing something i looked down she
had the key
there's the weirdest sucker that's so
weird yeah
she like came out of [ __ ] nowhere
yeah at which point i very nicely told
the poltergeist that he needed to um
send a million dollars to my paypal
account yeah that'd be great so please
poltergeist if you're listening yeah
just you know don't don't take it from
like an orphanage or anything but you
know take it from some [ __ ] somewhere
and put it in my paypal thanks
i'd appreciate
the key appeared out of nowhere right
into right into the pookie's hands maybe
because we'd been talking in the house
about how we blamed pokey for like
taking it away i was saying maybe took
it so it framed her
if it framed her yeah yeah she was like
she coughed it up but like i said the
the key is too big
she couldn't have eaten it no i mean
it's big it's like a mark on it it's
like that big yeah it's got a little so
it's not like she like pulled it out of
her butt or she like coughed it up or
anything i got four motorcycles that key
was to a buell lightning xb with the xp
and xb9 lightning
the other one was the xb12 lightning
or actually an xp-12 thunderbolt that
lightning bolt it's it's part lightning
and part thunder uh firebolt
it'll start off as a firebolt with a
lightning tail and a bunch of
modifications and stuff to it
so i got two built xb's but that one's
the the the lightning bolt is 12-3
but yeah so yeah we found the key
yeah
that's pretty creepy out of the blue
i kind of you know what i kind of
suspected that that was going to happen
yeah because we've had that kind of
thing happen before where it's like
something vanished
and then it'll be gone for like a couple
of weeks yeah and then we'll be like
where the [ __ ] is it and then it's like
it'll appear like right like in the
middle of the floor or something like
where you were it was there the whole
time you know what i mean even though
you searched that place like a zillion
times yeah i looked underneath the table
that this the television sits on looked
at it every angle it was there was
nothing there looked underneath the bed
picked all that stuff up there
and she didn't have enough time to find
it and bring it to me it wasn't there
before yeah cause there's nowhere she
can go really like when you're sitting
there at the end of the bed because
you're always like playing with her like
that on this little we have that long
one of those long like bench things that
you can lift up and store [ __ ] in and he
sits on that and it's like she doesn't
like she just runs like a foot it's just
like you know it's just floor there's
nothing else there
she just
ran towards me and threw herself on her
back and it came out and she grabbed it
she she thought i threw it to her i
didn't throw it to her
that's how [ __ ] happens yeah maybe she
sees that kind of [ __ ] all the time
well like i said it's like every now and
then you know
anybody that has cats or dogs you have
the experience the experience of them
just suddenly like they're doing
something and then they suddenly go
yeah yeah and look at this and then like
start staring like up in the closet and
i'd always tease her i'm like are you
looking at a ghost right now pookie you
can tell me
but she can't tell me
she wasn't upset or anything it seemed
she was just having fun yeah she didn't
notice anything on uh unusual that's
just weird huh it was very very weird
yeah real weird i mean i'm glad you
found it but
i'm glad it appeared rather
yeah it was given it was returned to me
yeah
well like i said you know just one of
the many million dollars one of them
poltergeist things that's happened over
the past couple years yeah probably
that's probably what one of maybe four
or five things five things that have
probably happened yeah yeah in recent
history
weird that is very weird
so so yeah so as i mentioned uh i
finished watching brand new cherry
flavor last night which a lot of people
uh had been recommending a lot of you
guys recommended it to me i saw like a
lot of horror channels recommending it i
actually quite enjoyed it it was weird
as [ __ ] and i'm all about that
um it is very uh
it has like a lot of david lynchian type
of aspects uh and then had some like
very cronenbergian
body horror
it's uh it's pretty gross so like if
you're not
if you're not down to this and not just
gore uh there's a lot of kind of like
vomiting like eating gross things you
know pulling worms out of eyeball
sockets like [ __ ] like that if that
shit's gonna bother you this is like
it's pretty nasty
so you might want to avoid um i haven't
read the book that it's based on i guess
based on a novel by todd grimson
and i was actually intrigued by this
because one of the creators of the show
is nick antaska and that's the guy who
does
channel zero which you have if you
haven't seen that series like an
anthology series um they have it on
shutter
uh what the [ __ ] channel was that on
originally i think it was on sci-fi
originally but i think um
but i've watched all of them so far but
they're all on shutter and they're all
like really good nick and tosca also has
something to do with the antlers which
i've been looking forward to seeing for
a long time like the wendigo movie so
this is like i don't even know it's kind
of horror but then it's also kind of
like
surrealist
noir kind of stuff it you know what it's
maybe this is totally off the wall it
kind of reminded me a little bit of
maybe something like dennis potter like
would have written like the singing
detective or something like that it gave
me a little bit of that kind of vibe too
but um so did you recognize who the star
of the uh of the show was like who that
girl was no
oh yeah i actually didn't think of it
either i'm like who the [ __ ] is that
girl that's uh rosa salazar that was a
elita
yeah yeah yeah yeah you just didn't
recognize her because they didn't do the
big eyes and [ __ ] like that on her yeah
because i have cg on her yeah yeah
that's that's who that was but yeah she
hasn't been in a lot of stuff but she
was actually like really great in this
yeah um
so the story and catherine keener is
also in this too and she's also
fantastic so the story if you don't know
i'm not gonna like spoil too much of it
like i said it's eight it's eight
episodes most of them are about 45 50
minutes long i think one of them is only
like 36 minutes or something so it's
about like seven eight hours like the
whole thing um and i'm not sure if
they're gonna do a second season because
i don't know
if where this ended was where the book
ended because i haven't read the book
so so i don't really know if they're
gonna it seemed like maybe they set it
up if they wanted to do like a second
season that they could
but they also kind of left it that if
they don't it's fine you know what i'm
saying
so the story about it it doesn't get
really weird i don't think until maybe
like the second episode
what happens is that um rosa salazar
plays this young woman and it's set in
the early 90s i think it's set in like
1991 or something like that so it has
like kind of a lot of 90s music or
something loving rockets i think there
was like some breeders maybe some belly
and stuff like that in there um but it's
not like super overbearing
um
so she plays like a young
uh movie director and she's made this
experimental short film called lucy's
eyes and apparently like some bad [ __ ]
happened like while she was filming it
they don't really tell you what it was
until later on in the series and so i'm
not going to either but apparently this
experimental film has attracted the
attention of a producer in la
uh whose name is lou burke
and so she drives from uh new york out
to la
and her and lou burke uh kind of start
working on this project he options uh
her film and he promises that we're
gonna make a full-length movie we're
gonna let you direct it blah blah blah
um and then uh it so happens that for
various reasons again which i will not
spoil um he kind of [ __ ] her over
and kind of kicks her off the project
at which point uh as one does she
decides to go to this woman played by
catherine keener who her name is boro
and she's like a tattoo artist she lives
like in this really weird like big kind
of crumbly house with this massive
massive greenhouse in the back
and uh she's a witch
so basically
what uh what lisa wants her to do is
curse this dude uh because she's super
super mad that he [ __ ] her over now it
sounds like a straightforward story but
it gets weirder and weirder and weirder
as the time goes on has to do
uh ultimately with
lisa's past um her mom who she didn't
know she was kind of goes in a little
bit um
like maybe like south american
uh you know jaguar spirit type of lore
it kind of goes into that as well
um but yeah it goes in like some pretty
strange directions uh there's
there's a thing where boro she takes her
payment in kittens
so
uh
so basically lisa like barfs up kittens
every now and then every now and then
um
and also there's one point there's one
point too where it's like she says she
doesn't want to barf up kittens anymore
at which point the witch kind of makes
like a
orifice like open in her side and then
kittens start popping out of that yeah
it gives her a side [ __ ] and then
there's yeah and then there's like one
of the world's weirdest sex scenes like
having to do with that yeah and it's
just like it's weird it's super super
bizarre like i said it's one of them
like something that oh what's his name
and do stan uh [ __ ] uh cronenberg
yeah well yeah like i said this is very
lynchy and it's david lynch mixed with
cronenberg
mixed with maybe some da some dennis
potter thrown in there it kind of
reminded me like it gave me
not i don't know i don't want to like
oversell that it kind of like seemed
like mulholland drive it did in the
sense that it's set in la and it's very
much a dark side of hollywood type of
story it doesn't have like the kind of
glammy type of stuff i feel like that
mulholland drive had um i saw this
compared a little bit to um cronenberg's
move like existence which kind of it is
i guess because that one came out in the
90s as well so it has that same kind of
vibe to it but
i don't know i really dug it the only
complaint
is that um i think the end was a tiny
bit anti-climactic
uh and for that reason i think that
maybe they're planning on doing another
season of it but like i said i'm not
sure if we're like where the book ends
um and i'm not sure if they're going on
with like another character
um because like it's it's hard to like
say sort of how it ended without ruining
it but i kind of feel like
maybe they're gonna go
with uh you know another main character
rather than lisa and they're gonna
follow that story instead so they could
possibly do that
um
but that said it's just like
like i said i'm not even sure if i'd
call this horror it is but
it's just it's one of the weirdest
things i've ever seen which is which is
kind of saying something
um but everything in it everybody in it
uh all the actors are great uh and
everybody like just commits to this like
weirdest [ __ ]
premise um which
even though it kind of has like a lot of
surrealist kind of [ __ ] in it like you
know as
as the curse progresses
um you know lisa's apartment like she
starts growing vines all over it and
like suddenly there's like a uh like a
trapdoor in the floor that just appears
so it's very it's very channel zero if
you've seen channel zero uh that show it
has a lot of that kind of vibe to it as
well because i remember there was one
channel zero where um where a door just
like appeared in somebody's basement or
something like that those are based on
uh creepypastas in case you guys didn't
know and i just like i said i would
recommend that show as well um some of
the you know some of the um
seasons are better than others but all
of them are worth watching and as far as
i know they're still all on shutter
because that's where i watched them but
this so this has a little bit of vibe at
that too but this is much weirder and
it's a lot more
graphic so like i said if you're not
really into
watching people barf up cats or eat
human ears in a stew or
drink cat blood or like i said pull
worms out of people's eye sockets or
something like that then maybe don't but
um but it is pretty [ __ ] gross so
just like know that going in but
i don't know overall like i really dug
it like i said i thought like the end
was slightly like a little bit
anticlimactic but
that's pretty much the only criticism um
i don't know i feel like i saw a lot of
uh
pretty positive reviews of it in the
horror community um so you know it's
cool that they're doing something this
different you know what i mean yeah
because i feel like there's so much
stuff that's just like it looked it
looked good to me yeah i just didn't
really have time to watch at all and
it's one and it's definitely it's one of
those shows where you really really have
to pay attention to like what's going on
because because the story is like so
bizarre and the backstory is so bizarre
and a lot of it isn't really spelled out
um explicitly uh some of it is
implication and symbolism and stuff so
it's like it's one of those ones where
you really kind of have to pay attention
i didn't realize how the sounds are but
now you mentioned it i see it now
yeah it was bugging me the whole time
like i'm watching going god damn it it's
like she's so familiar but then it like
hit me like after i finished watching
i'm like oh my god it's elita
yeah and if you guys haven't seen battle
angel see it that was one of the best
movies of that year i bought that on
blu-ray i loved that movie
um
i don't know if they'll make another
sequel or not uh i don't think it did as
well as they wanted it to do but it
built a real strong fan base people were
like no give us another one
but for some reason you know [ __ ]
they
they didn't sound too interested in
doing another one i thought it was great
i thought it was great i mean eventually
they might do another one i feel like it
did well enough because like i said
they've made sequels to movies that
didn't do as well as that so i don't
really see why they wouldn't get around
they had a bunch of sets made
most of the movie was cg
it looked like it looked like an anime
full color and kind of like anime
um
and they had a bunch of sets made and
they said that they'd be able to do all
kinds of sequels
um but it they i think they thought it
was going to blow it out of the park and
they'd get on get onto a sequel right
away i mean you know
now at this point [ __ ] it would be
you know a couple years from now yeah
but you know like i said that's kind of
i don't know that's kind of how [ __ ]
happens but um it was that story came
from a manga and the fans of the manga
[ __ ] loved it they said yeah that
that's pretty much it they wanted
another one which it was much better
than ghost in the shell and that wasn't
a bad movie it's just the fans of ghost
in the shell didn't like that
that movie i didn't uh i didn't love it
it to me great it looked good but i
couldn't um it wasn't a real it just
wasn't yeah it wasn't real compelling
yeah like i couldn't like it looked cool
it didn't look like a bad movie i just
it couldn't hold my interest yeah just
there it was just kind of blah
the story was blah camp guy asked i
didn't understand what boro did with the
kittens um i think familiars i think
well i don't think she was killing them
i think at one point she was like
drinking their blood like she would take
because i think there was one scene
where she was like uh took a syringe and
like took blood she didn't kill it but
she just like took a little bit of blood
out in a syringe and then like she would
keep it she had like a little fridge and
she would keep it so that was like
giving her power
um i think but because the thing about
it is this a spoiler or not i don't know
if it is i'm sorry but the thing about
boro is that she um
she could go from body to body
and i think that the cat blood was like
helping her
stay in one body and like keeping it
together type of thing until she could
like jump into the next one she gave her
familiar to her though didn't she change
the familiars out
she just well at the beginning she
always had like cats around there was
always like a bunch of cats around and
um it ended up
well the cat yeah i guess the cats were
kind of familiar because remember like
in the first or second episode you know
after um she had like after uh lisa had
gone and like you know said hey curse
this dude uh basically said quote
unquote set his life on fire they
shouldn't want to kill him she wanted
him to suffer
so
and then one of um borrows cats this
really cute one i don't know if
was it cg or was it that a real cat
because i mean it was a real cat
obviously but i didn't know if they
because its head looked kind of it
looked like a sphinx but with fur if
that makes any sense so um so that cat
like came to
lisa's house
and then because late because earlier
like boro had said something to her like
hey bring back my cat like when you come
back
because like she knew that the cat was
gonna go there but i don't think she was
i don't think she was doing anything
necessarily bad to the cats they were
just kind of like milling around and she
would just like periodically to like
take blood from them and that was like
because like i said it was this whole
like south american jaguar yeah type of
power yeah desolate one the woman was
was the girl it was salazar
that was the the actress salazar wrote
rosa salazar rose and salazar yeah yeah
she played battle angel yeah in a later
battle angel but you know they kind of
tweaked her head a little bit made her
eyes a little bit bigger made her look
more like an anime drawing yeah
um
but no i was the same actress
as
if you haven't seen battle angel see it
that's a good movie i liked it
she was she was a robot or an android
right yeah an android yeah
i don't think she had a human brain in
her did she
she just was just
she was just she was alive yeah and i
don't think it was ai i mean i think it
was i right
as far as i remember yeah i mean we saw
it a couple times but i haven't seen it
she was a living robot in a way yeah um
she's made to be a
soldier
but not on this planet on another planet
you gotta watch it it's a good movie
the desolate one says who plays the
witch in this show uh catherine keener
and she's actually like she's [ __ ]
great in this uh you know and she's just
i don't know i think she probably is my
favorite character in this one although
i don't know man there was just like so
many there's [ __ ] oh there's all the
cats there's zombies in this there's
like somebody getting their head pulled
off it's just it's fun it's fun and it's
weird and you can't really ask much more
than that uh you know what i did last
night after since since we kind of like
cause like i said it's hard for me to
talk about spoiling it because i know
some of you have seen it but some of you
probably haven't but if you're into
weird [ __ ] then totally like weird gross
[ __ ] totally watch it because it's super
bizarre
um after i finished watching that i was
like pretty tired and i was kind of like
well
i need to watch um
the crazies because that's going to be
our movie retrospective but i was like
so tired
that i wanted to pick something else and
then netflix has this new documentary i
don't know if any of you watched it it's
about bob ross
um sort of it's actually kind of about
it's called what's it called bob ross
happy accidents
um
greed and betrayal or betrayal and grade
i can't remember and it's basically like
bob ross's son
and he's kind of like talking about
what happened like after bob ross died
um you know the business partners of bob
ross kind of like licensing his name and
his image even though that wasn't really
what bob ross wanted when he was alive
and you know making all the money
off of his off of his dad's like name
and face because like i said there's bob
ross [ __ ] everywhere like nowadays you
can go to like they got whole stores
that sell like mugs and t-shirts and
stuff
and um his estate
or his family doesn't get any of that
money as far as i know maybe his half
brother does but there's all kind of
like legal allegedly allegedly because i
was like his business partners they said
they're very sue happy
um
so yeah which is why but it's really
good it's like it goes a lot into like
bob ross and how he got started and
has a lot of clips from the show and
stuff which is like always like really
relaxing to watch and uh it's nice
because he seemed like a really nice
dude and kind of seemed like a shame
what happened like after he died and
stuff but that but that was really good
too so i'd also uh recommend that i
might talk about that more on the side
track show
but um
because
[ __ ] happy little trees but uh but
yeah so
if anybody else i saw the um trailer
forks i think louie yesterday said that
um there was a new movie on netflix
called the old ways and i saw that
that's a movie right it's not a series
so i saw the trailer for that and that
looks actually pretty good too although
i've been wanting to watch i think it
came out a while back on shutter it's a
shutter exclusive called psycho gorman
which is supposed to be like this crazy
like over-the-top horror comedy and i've
kind of been wanting to see that because
i've seen like a bunch of people like
recommend that and it sounds super fun
so i don't know i might watch that
tonight too and we'll talk about that
tomorrow but i don't know depends it
sounds like something you would like
okay
you know what i'm saying all right
well i know i know i'm just saying i
haven't seen it either i'm just saying
all right so we will be back tomorrow
talking about whatever we decide to
watch tonight thanks everybody for
dropping by we will see you guys again
tomorrow afternoon bye